problems famous you don't get to meet
the cast but you did get to meet Sir
Elton at the Perimeter Elton John is one
of the producers of the film and
provides a lot of the music and he is
the only reason I did it because I'm a
huge fan and I'll be honest with you
trying to get free tickets for his
forthcoming concert tour that's my plan
and I saw me the premiere and well I
tried to insinuate you know when you
don't want to be you don't to be on the
knows about it so looking forward to
you're looking forward to your concert
tour you said yeah it should be a lot of
fun yeah yeah I mean it's gonna be tough
getting tickets isn't it well is
there'll be more release soon I'm
thinking come on Rocket Man weave
between the lines
but anyway maybe if I can mention it now
because sometimes you know if you say
something on TV they'll send you it I'd
love to see out in John in concert with
like me and play for my friends in a VIP
area also aren't Rolex watches great
come on guys it's too it's too the
classic design you know in that's full
of love mercedes-benz as well talking of
meeting various positions
was it bono that you're good friends
with Tamsin you've met him Doug I did
meet bono I was nine months pregnant and
I was asked to present an award at the
GQ Awards right I'm on the telly that's
why they've asked me so me and Julien
went up went down I'm like this
absolutely massive thought I was sort of
like this so it was really but wasn't it
was like a problem you know and went up
the award Awards pregnant Oh
on stage sorry I'm just you know if I
have to leave can I call it bono and
there was his little voice that went
girls like their audience which was
charmed me and then afterwards he came
up to me and got down on his hands and
knees and kissed my belly as though he
was blessing it like the Pope like the
Pope and said he thought it was the most
beautiful thing he'd ever seen and so I
asked him for tickets to his concert I
didn't get them how the worries about
these musicians and then my daughter
goes around saying Bono kissed me she
did she says he's actually kissing she
should be careful where she
[Music]
you